there's a lot more visibility I you know
I was thinking about prompted by this
question well what was it like for gay
folks when I was growing up there were
no gay folks there was no one that was
out at my high school I think there was
one woman at college and this is not
that long ago we weren't you know we're
talking about the 90s and it just wasn't
talked about did you just didn't see it
people made gay jokes anti gay jokes in
high school and I remember you know my
boyfriend and I at the time were both
really pretty progressive compared to
other folks we went to high school with
and so we would sort of stand up to
people and it was you know we were in
the minority definitely but no one was
out and I the young people that I see at
the center and the kids that I see come
to the center they run the gamut you
know what I see that really surprises
and inspires me is the kids who are so
confident and so secure and so like yep
I'm gay I know it Here I am love me you
know and whether it's a front or it's
real the fact that it even exists is
fabulous and something to be nurtured
and then there are the kids you know I
do sit on the mayor's Commission which
ended recently for LGBT runaway and
homeless youth and it's a big problem
you're an LGBT young person not living
in New York City and you're not accepted
by your family and you don't have a
supportive environment a lot of those
kids come to New York and it's expensive
here it's challenging it's isolating we
see a lot of them at the center we serve
a lot of them at the center and they
really need our support an hour you know
they need resources they need a place to
sleep they
needs someone who tells them that
they're okay that it's okay to be who
they are so I really see the entire
spectrum when it comes to young people
and you know I met recently for Pride
Week one of the grand marshals was
constance mcmillen who is the lesbian
woman who wanted to bring another woman
to her prom and wear a tux and the
school said no and they cancel the prom
and then they faked a prom so she would
not be able to go to it and just this
horrific story and she is so confident
and so inspirational every step of the
way and wants to go to college and get
her PhD and counsel you know other gay
kids and support them and that's just
amazing it's it's terrible that we still
have to deal with that kind of blatant
almost proud bigotry from her school and
her classmates but it's amazing that she
is standing up and not backing down and
saying that she deserves to be treated
equally so I think the young people
today the young LGBT people are really
an inspiration and a reason why we all
need to engage in the fight to achieve
basic rights and protections and
treatment so in the media there's such
pressure for everybody to conform gay
straight you know you should be
beautiful you should be thin you should
be rich and you should be endlessly
interesting I mean that's what reality
television and some of the media and
generalists is telling us so I think
it's up to all of us to be who we are
and present a different picture and show
the world and all of its many facets
and support that and find ways to really
really support that because things do
get a very homogenous and very
anesthetize through the media everything
does and it's why I think we need to
look outside and build our at the
outside of the media build our own
communities talk to real people and just
create a world where we can all be who
we want to be